vamos a trazar un par de rectas
paralelas ahí tenemos una ahí tenemos la
otra déjame indicar que son rectas
poniéndole flechitas al final y voy a
marcar que son paralelas poniéndole esta
marca naranja estaba en esa dirección y
esta también bueno además de estas dos
rectas paralelas también vamos a pintar
una transversal una recta que corte a
ambas esta de acá y esta de acá y vamos
a pensar que este ángulo es de 110
grados bueno con esta información que
otros ángulos podemos determinar en esta
figura bueno empecemos notando que este
ángulo es correspondiente con este de
acá con las rectas paralelas y la
transversal entonces deben medir lo
mismo podemos pensar los como los
ángulos que están arriba a la izquierda
arriba a la izquierda vale bueno además
de esto tenemos que este ángulo de aquí
abajo es opuesto por el vértice con este
de acá entonces también son congruentes
y éste mide 110 grados y ahora para
determinar éste lo podemos pensar como
opuesto por el vértice de este de acá o
sea un argumento análogo de modo que
mide 110 grados o bien lo podemos pensar
como ángulo correspondiente con las
rectas paralelas y la transversal a este
de acá y entonces pues también sale que
mide 110 grados vale ahora pasemos a
este ángulo que voy a pintar en rosa
este ángulo en rosa junto con el de 110
grados hace en la recta amarilla es
decir hacen 180 grados son
suplementarios como este ya es 110
grados este de acá deben ser debe de ser
de 70 grados para que sumen 180 grados
vale ahora este de acá es opuesto por el
vértice a éste de modo que es de 70
grados y este es correspondiente con
este de acá por lo tanto este también es
de 70 grados o bien éste lo pudimos
haber pensado como suplementario de este
de 110 grados o incluso de este de acá
este de 70 grados con este de 110 forman
la recta azul así que deben de sumar 180
grados vale y finalmente este ángulo que
queda aquí abajito lo podemos pensar de
muchas formas ya sea como el
suplementario de 110 como el opuesto por
el vértice de 70 o como el
correspondiente de 70 grados pero no
importa cómo lo pensemos nos queda que
mide 70 grados